let's talk about the hypothetical spec
script let's suppose
i want to get on a show what would be my
method to doing that would i write about
an episode that already
exists you know a continuation of one
yeah in television these days to get to
be in consideration
for getting your first writing job on
staff of a show
which means you didn't sell your own
original show you got hired to write for
someone else's show which is still the
much more likely scenario for a new
writer right
people are writing original pilots and
hoping to sell them and get them you
know on
in front of an audience of course and
there's always a chance that that could
happen but it's you know of course
very rare today you know people writing
original pilots
you know within the industry people that
have managers and agents running
original pilots
if they don't already have a big track
record writing for television or film
and a lot of success
they're probably writing that as a
writing sample to try and get a job on
staff of a series
and what has changed in the like 20
years since i was doing that
is that back in like the 90s and before
the traditional way to get hired on
staff of a series was to write what they
would call a spec episode of an existing
show
just what it's just some successful
relatively new show that people in the
industry liked and respected like
seinfeld was the big show to do like
during its like second seasons about the
right time
where people are writing these their own
ideas for an original seinfeld episode
that hopefully
reads like a like a really good episode
of seinfeld like you read the script and
you go this feels like it could be on
that show it would be a really good
episode that show they capture the
voices it's very funny
etc etc not easy to do really well easy
to do mediocrely
not easy to do well enough that people
go wow
which of course that's what you want
when you're a screenwriter it's like to
get that wow is rare and sought after
right
so back then very few people wrote
original pilots if they weren't already
established because there was nothing to
do with them
they weren't looking for original
palettes as writing samples as much they
wanted to know that you could write in
another writer's voice
an episode of a show that already
existed which of course is what you
would be doing if you got hired on staff
for some reason in the last 20 years
that has shifted a lot
what i've heard anecdotally is where in
those days 80
of it was specs of existing shows
nowadays it's more like 80
or original pilots that people are
writing and that is what is getting the
managers and agents and getting them
their first jobs on a series
on a writing staff people still do write
specs of existing shows
i think you definitely need to write
them to get into some of the big
fellowships that some of the studios and
networks offer which are great
ways to try and break into tv writing
but
what's much more in vogue is writers
writing original pilots for series that
they came up with
and those pilots become their main
writing sample or samples
that they use to try to first get a
manager and then get an agent
which you usually kind of have to go
step by step and then
have their managers and agents sending
them to production companies showrunners
executives at the studios and networks
and
streaming services uh to try to get you
noticed as a potential tv staff
writer and so how long would these spec
scripts be i mean
so it's going to be like half hour
content or yeah it's going to be this
would be the same length as a typical
script for the show you're writing for
well if it's original a show
of the ilk of what you're writing in
other words if you're writing a one hour
clearly a network style drama it's going
to be about
you know it's going to be like a 45
minute because there would be
commercials
and then how many pages that translates
to you know they say a minute of page
you can go a little long in a spec
i would say a one hour pilot maybe like
60 pages would probably be the max you
would want to go for
for an original pilot you're really
trying to sort of like
copy what successful shows that are
similar to yours
would do in terms of links so it's
really helpful to read scripts not just
watch
episodes of the kind of shows that you
inspire you that you would want to
you know write something in that genre
whether it's like an hbo type
show or a netflix type show nowadays
those
services have shows that can have
different length episodes and different
length scripts so that they're not a
standard like 21 minute
half hour comedy on abc kind of thing
it's a little more there's some
flexibility i think so you don't have to
be too
nervous about the exact right number of
pages but generally you're emulating
what is standard for the kind of script
that you're writing
and why do you say it's so hard to make
a great
spec script it's easier to make a
mediocre one what's the
well when you're writing a spec episode
of an existing show i think it's
it's easy-ish to write something where
the characters talk kind of how they
talk on the real show
you know and you have the kind of jokes
that you can imagine they would kind of
have but maybe they're not great jokes
but they're just kind of like
sort of okay jokes and the kind of story
and kind of behavior of the characters
that
is their typical behavior like it's not
so hard to sort of mimic
that it's hard to mimic it in a way
that's as good or better than the actual
produced show
is because really for uh one of those
scripts to stand out i was always told
it has to actually be better
than an average episode it has to feel
like why haven't they done this episode
it's like a great idea it's perfect for
the show it's really funny it's really
memorable
if it's a comedy obviously you're going
for the funny and that's just hard to
do really well it looks it looks easy
which is why i try to do it
it looks easy to write a show that you
know that's a good show
to come up with your own ideas for
stories for an episode
but to do it on a level that would that
someone would hire you based on it
is not easy and and normally the show
you wrote it for is not going to hire
you they're probably not even going to
want to read it
they probably will be tougher on it than
any other show would be because they
know their shows so well
and they probably aren't looking for
writers because they're already on the
air and a hit
so typically when you're breaking into
television you're breaking in with a
staff writing job on a brand new show
that no one's ever seen before
you may not even love the show but it's
where they offered you a job based on
reading your stuff
and it may be a show that gets canceled
its first season because most of them do
but that's kind of like the life of a of
a what they call a baby writer a writer
breaking into television and working on
staff
but most of that doesn't apply as much
today because people are writing
original pilots instead of
specs but obviously it's really hard to
write an original pilot that impresses
people too
perhaps harder because now you're coming
up with characters and a whole situation
that they don't know anything about and
you have to make them
you know care about these characters be
entertained be intrigued and all that
kind of stuff
and all the problems of the show have to
be really compelling
whereas if you're writing a spec episode
of an existing show
a lot of that has already been done for
you right you just have to write a
variation on something that
someone else has already established and
maybe that's why nowadays those aren't
valued as much because people can say
well
you didn't have to do as much to do that
on the other hand when you write on
staff of a show
a big part of your job is mimicking the
voice of the show runner
being able to execute the show in a way
that they would like the way they would
have done it
which is a not a skill that every writer
has
so to show you can write uh somebody
else's show in their voice really well
i think still is a very valuable thing
but the industry
is more interested in original pilots um
for
writing samples despite that i think
these days
but you say it's rare that let's suppose
seinfeld i'm writing you know it's
it's still in existence and i'm writing
that that i'm submitting this to and
thinking that i'm going to be
in the writer's room for seinfeld no i'm
submitting it for
friends or something well you're
submitting you're not even making it for
friends you're submitting for some show
that hasn't been on the air yet i mean
that's the reality because you
you know your your agent would be the
one doing all the submitting right so
first you have to impress
an agent enough to get an agent but once
you have an agent
they're going to be submitting these
these new potential writers to all those
brand new shows that just found out they
got a series order and now they have to
staff up
shows that have already been on the air
they already have a staff they may have
one person leave and they fill one
vacancy but
basically they're already there so
you're never
almost never going to get on a
successful existing hit show that you
love or that you would have written a
spec
of you're going to use that spec to get
on some brand new unknown show that you
may or may not love
or may or may not be right for but it's
they thought you were right for it based
on your script so
there you go
you